JORDAN THOMAS: If I can
make one person's day better,
then my day's infinitely better.
And I think that it's
part of the culture
here is, you always hear in
the service of humanity.
That motto's really started to
strike home a lot more for me
and really thinking
critically about well,
how can I be in the
service of humanity?
That's something I really
do take seriously now.
I'm Jordan Thomas.
I'm in the Class of 2018.
I'm a Woodrow
Wilson School major
pursuing dual certificates in
Portuguese language and culture
and African American studies.
My mother's side of
the family are actually
immigrants from Portugal.
I grew up learning English and
Portuguese at the same time.
So I really could just speak a
sort of household Portuguese.
And so I decided that I wanted
to reach the next level.
Portuguese has really come to
define my Princeton experience
in certain ways.
And so I've loved it.
Now, I can write essays.
I spent a whole summer, part
of it in Portugal part of it
in Brazil, and it really
has been one of the better
decisions I've made.
ELIZABETH ARMSTRONG: I first met
Jordan when he was a freshman.
I was his freshman adviser.
And from the start,
Jordan really
stood out as a special
kind of student.
One of the things that I
really like about Jordan
is his humility.
Jordan, in fact, is
always looking for a way
to give back rather than taking
for granted what he has here.
He's engaged.
He's a scholar.
He's a citizen.
JORDAN THOMAS:
For my thesis,
I'll be looking at
support services
for pregnant and
parenting teens,
specifically, in the Newark
Public School District.
We know now the correlation
between education and health,
education and income--
all of these other really
important later life outcomes.
I feel like it's
very valuable that we
make sure that if
these girls are dealing
with unplanned
pregnancies, we still
make sure that they have
the support they need
to complete their education and
get their high school diploma.
In the end, hopefully,
we'll have a good sense
of what support services
and programs are
in place for pregnant
and parenting teens
in high school in Newark.
And if there's anything
that can ultimately
be done to improve the
services, hopefully, we'll
have a good sense
of that as well.
So after Princeton, I would say
that my most immediate plans
are to travel to Oxford
as a Rhodes Scholar
and integrate into their
master's program for two years
there.
After completing the
master's program,
I then plan to return to
the U.S. and go to law school
because my longer-term
plans down the road
are to ultimately enter
into the policy sphere
and run for public
office, whether that be
at the state or federal level.
One thing that I've
really taken to heart
is never forget
where I came from
and that really Newark shaped
me in a number of ways.
And I couldn't have
come here, and I
couldn't have done
the things that I've
done here without the special
impact that Newark had on me.
I feel like one of
the most concerning
things about lower-income
minority-based districts and
schools is that you
see students that are really
talented and really gifted.
Despite having
the qualifications
and being just as
prepared as some
of the other students in
suburban districts to apply,
they decide not to apply.
And so I always go to these
students, and I let them know,
no if you have the
qualifications,
go ahead and submit
that application.
You are qualified.
You can do the work, and I
try to really lead by example
and showing them
look, I did this.
Hopefully, through
the work that I've
done here and through
the work that I'll
continue doing in the future,
I'm impacting people in ways
that I've never known and
extending my reach to people
that I'll never know.
And there's just something
so beautiful about that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]